hello folks
welcome to
rational science
we have a great day today we're going to
be talking about dark matter
and we're going to find out that the
mathematicians
are
full of dark matter
anyways uh we had a uh
people put a lot of comments regarding
um
the moon
had a lot of moonies and one of the
things uh that really
surprised me is the number of people
that do not believe that we landed on
the moon
and i don't know if it's just a new
generation or you know that
did not
experience what happened in 1969
or
it's is it people that
you know don't like government uh
telling them so many lies and so they
stopped believing in everything they
threw away the baby together with the
wash water
i don't know what the issue is but
uh you know in my mind i thought it was
maybe i don't know one or two percent
people out there that did not believe
that we went to the moon
turns out that
i had to revise my estimate i think
maybe there's anywhere from 10 to 20
percent people out there that
probably do not believe that humans went
to the moon
and that was kind of surprising for me
anyways uh
here this is what i'm going to be
addressing first uh half because there
were so many issues with the moon i
don't think i can touch anything else
and here yeah we're gonna deal with the
moonies again okay
okay so let's find out what these people
are all about okay
and there are several issues involving
the moon as well that people commented
on
so uh here's the first vowel he said uh
the moon doesn't orbit around the earth
the moon doesn't around the earth
and uh
this is like you know someone showing
pointing at white and saying
that's black
and you look again just in case your
your eyes failed you
know that
that's white
and the guy saying no no you're staring
at black
i mean you know here you see uh he
points to an
um
site in youtube i go there find out what
it's all about maybe they've got a
different kind of moon or something i
don't know maybe talking about a moon of
another planet you know
and what you see is first uh that it's
it's our planet it's our moon i guess
that's what they seem to show there
right that's what they talk about
and you can see the first error there is
that you know the moon goes at the same
rate as the earth
okay and uh
that's a big problem because the earth
turns on its axis every 24 hours whereas
the moon you know takes 27 days to go
around you know the earth so the speeds
there are a little different that's the
first issue
and then the other issue is whether the
moon goes around the earth let me repeat
that because you may have not understood
what this guy said the moon
goes around the earth does it go around
the earth or not well for this we got to
look at the word around
this guy doesn't seem to know english
maybe he's uh you know from mexico or
someplace you know uh says if you look
up the word around it says in a circle
ring or the light so as to surround a
person group thing etc yeah it looks
like uh that moon is surrounding all
around the earth okay on all sides
which is what you see there
and in all direction from a center or
point of reference
so yeah the moon goes around the earth
sorry to tell you that
uh you know but i guess uh you know i
don't know if people want to sound cute
or or what so the first thing is the the
moon does go around the earth goes all
around in fact every
um
part of the earth it doesn't matter
where you're at uh you could be in
africa you could be in china and in the
americas
you should be able to see the moon at
some point uh
in time you know during the month
and uh and that's because the moon goes
all around the earth so yeah the moon
does go around the earth i don't know
how else to tell you that but yeah some
people say that white is black and uh
they're staring at white okay and that's
essentially what we've got here
and then the other issue again is that
the
moon is not uh or the whole
orbit is not um
illustrated properly okay it's not
illustrated properly what's wrong well
what's wrong is that you know again the
moon
uh always shows us the same face but the
earth spins a lot faster than the moon
goes around the earth
and so you know
every part of the earth
has a chance to see the one side of the
moon okay
and so yeah
i don't know what uh these people are
thinking maybe they want to sound cute
the guy who made that video has no clue
about anything
and uh and what's interesting you know
they get a they get thousands of hits
and people go ah
and then they bring it here
it's just great
okay another fellow says
another mooney okay we got we got a lot
of moonies here
moon takes 27 days to rotate around its
axis
according to the model
okay you did not do your homework on
this
me
uh you believe this like a religion it
seems
well i don't know maybe he's a flat
earther he doesn't believe that
the moon uh
you know uh goes
you know around the earth every 27 days
it does that's one issue maybe that he
was referring to that maybe he was
referring to spin maybe he was saying
you know the
moon does indeed spin but the spin is
equal to its orbit
absolute nonsense absolute nonsense so
let's clarify that for all the
you know mental cases that we have out
there let's let's clarify that kill that
once and for all the moon does not spin
okay
here i have a pencil okay we have a
pencil
let's see if you can follow it let's see
if you have the intelligence to follow
this
let's color code
the pencil we'll put red on this side
and blue on this side okay so we're
going to have red on this i should have
done that but just i think you can
follow it red on this side blue on this
side
does the earth spin
yes it does and let me tell you why
because if this is the axis
of the earth going right through you
know north pole to the south pole right
well africa will be looking at red at
some point and at some point it will be
looking at blue
because it twirls around the whole earth
twirls around
africa at some point will face red at
some point it will face from this side
you know face blue
because it's twirling around
if we do the same thing with the moon
okay we put an axis right through the
center of the moon
anywhere you want okay i don't care
because it doesn't matter in the case of
the moon
well uh the earth the the moon might go
around the earth always showing the same
face
but any point on the surface of the moon
you know the one that's facing red will
always face red more or less because it
wobbles a little bit right but it'll
face red any any other point will face
blue
and no matter what the the moon can
stand on its head if it wants it's
always going to show
a mountain a given mountain you know a
hill whatever to the red and the other
one's going gonna show it to blue
because it does not spin let me tell you
what spinning looks like okay i know you
guys are
see this is what happens when you skip
kindergarten okay in elementary school
okay this is what a uh spin looks like
okay and again the reason it spins is
that if that axis
if we if we could re make it remain uh
fixed okay
so that we could gauge whether it's
spinning or not
any point on the surface of that top
is going to change locations with
respect to some place on the axis if we
could color code it have red on one side
blue on the other side
whatever edge that you want to pick on
that top
will sometimes see red and sometimes see
blue that's not the case with a moon
the moon does not
spin
okay and only people who don't
understand that will say that well the
moon doesn't
spins
or equals its rotation or whatever
yeah these people think they're cute and
they're trying to sound uh
intelligent all they do is just show
their ignorance uh haven't even done the
research on it no the moon does not spin
okay in any way shape or form of the
word spin okay the fact that it rotates
or revolves or orbits the earth around
the earth right it does go around the
earth while doing so it does not spin
with respect to an imaginary axis that
it could have you know that you could
put in there by hand
okay moving on here we have another more
moonies to deal with today a bunch of
moonies
we didn't go to the moon says one guy
the earth is a sphere atoms are not
orbiting balls
well they look like orbiting balls to me
i mean that's how everybody puts atoms
you know with all these little beads
moving around
and you know the the issue here is that
people say what it ain't
don't tell me what it ain't
tell me what is
that's where you show a little
intelligence but says atoms are not
orbiting beads okay they're not or balls
or whatever uh if they're not orbiting
balls tell me what it is please draw a
picture or put in a link and say look
here's the true genuine
atom
because when you look at the atom
anywhere you want to look at it that's
what you see you see orbiting beads
so don't tell me that the atom is not
orbiting beads because that's what it
that's what everybody uses out there in
fact
uh quantum mechanics would not be able
to explain electricity the way it does
today unless
uh the atom consisted of orbiting beads
because they're going to take one of
these little beads called an electron
they're going to move it around
from atom to atom sometimes without
atoms as we discussed a couple of
uh lectures ago
so
yeah the the atom that is used by all of
quantum mechanics has not changed since
the day niels bohr and uh ernst uh
russell ford came up with it which is
the planetary model
okay
that's the atom that's used for
ionization that's the atom that's used
for electricity and that's the end
that's denied at the end of the
conference saying well that's not our
true atom
and that's what this person did he says
that's not the atom okay then what is
okay and yeah he says you didn't go to
the moon yeah i guess
you know statements
no justification no argument just we
didn't
i don't believe it
okay
here's another fellow he says proof oh
sorry bill one of your worst vids ever
okay
in
insane ramblings and gibberish from you
to support such an obvious nasa fraud
nasa have lost all tapes of moon
landings and proof
oops
well i don't know about that i mean he
thinks maybe it was all filmed in
hollywood or something why would nasa
what would be the motive for nasa for 60
years because if it's one deal like you
know jfk's death you know you uh it's
easy to argue that this was done by
johnson and
jay edgar and uh uh alan dulles um
911 yeah uh you know
uh what's his name uh
george bush's crew no problem why
because it was one day was one one
minute you know it was a short time
and then immediately goes into history
and then all you can do is rely on maybe
some pictures that someone took out
there etc
here we're talking about 60 years of
nasa 60 at least i mean you know i'm
sure it's uh right after the world war
one same for the russians
and so these guys been
uh sending rockets out there okay for 60
years and you're telling me
that uh all that is fake there were no
rockets uh we've never gone into space
okay and uh we've never orbited the
earth we haven't put a um
a lab out there in the sky in a skylab
rolling around the earth that has that
not only hasn't happened but is not
happening
that's all fake
and and this is very easy to kill your
ignorance i mean kill your ignorance
okay
and what i'm saying is go to florida
the next launch
take your camera your height you know
high-powered camera right take your
telescope
and film the damn rocket go into space
okay you can see it go go go go until
it's gone
and so don't come with nonsense with
idiocy saying that
we haven't gone to space for example
some people because there are different
levels some people say we haven't gone
to the moon others say we haven't gone
into space other people say we don't
even have satellites out there that's
all done you know
i mean these people are so ignorant
it's more than ignorance it's something
if they want to kill their ignorance
there are ways of showing that i mean
the time they spend arguing they could
go to
again florida and just film it
or get a friend to do it over there you
know call call the flat earthers over
there in florida and say please flat
earthers the flood of their society
would you be so kindness to film
the rocket go to space next time around
i mean you have to be a total ignoramus
and so now is homework i want you to
look at the mirror okay this uh coming
uh
thursday or friday okay look at the
mirror and ten times say to the guy in
the mirror you're an ignoramus five
times at least
ten times always looking at mecca okay
my god
another flat earther okay here we have
your moonies flat earthers impossible
for something to be flat with hills
mountains depressions valleys elevations
what i don't observe is over half my
nearest mountain under curvature isn't
hidden
uh
i can't i can see over 100 miles away a
mountain from bottom to top anything can
be around my table is round
so uh
see these people want to prove
flatness or curvature by
saying well when i look at the highway
it looks pretty straight to me
yeah no kidding you know one of the
issues there is when they built the uh
the siberian railroad probably the
longest uh
thing we've got on earth you know uh
um
constructed in the 19th century and it
went you know from one side of russia to
the other side of russia
and of course it went into hills and
valleys because you know as far as i
know no country is evenly flat and then
you have the curvature of the earth and
you know russia has a significant
portion of the curvature on earth
so not only does it go you know over
mountains and hills but it goes over a
curvature that has mountains and hills
and
maybe you should contact those
architects and engineers
who built the trans siberian railroad
and they can tell you all the problems
they ended up having because the earth
is not so flat and again not only
because of hills and valleys okay but
because the earth is curved
okay
and so you know for flat earthers what
can i tell you you know
uh they proved proved that the earth was
around
what was in the days of the greek
and uh yeah you don't have to believe
that proof because again we don't have
proofs
in
science but here you have a good
argument uh put forth by the greeks of
why the earth was round and you should
read up on that you know okay and uh
here's another felony he says
it is so easy to get to and from
the moon
with technology from the 60s
then today for every nation that has
developed space
technology they would have their own
lunar base or an international complex
like that shack that orbit around the
earth
okay so uh if it's so easy why don't we
have uh lunar bases why isn't everybody
on the moon
and he says i could come and go from the
moon for my christmas or summer holidays
do lots of selfie and look at the blue
pearl from the window of the luna hotel
you know
what can i tell these people you know
there's was no reason to ever go to the
moon in the first place
and there is no reason to go to it now
now why did they go to the moon well
they went there not so much for the moon
because they realized that it was a
bunch of rocks they could maybe find
something on the moon maybe a little bug
crawling that they never thought about
yeah
they could have had some surprise okay
but the issue was to develop technology
that was the primary reason other than
that going to the moon saying we did it
we made it to the moon
and again the hope which is still in
nasa and all these other space agencies
is that someday we will be colonizing
space
especially you know planets first maybe
the moon right or other moons and then
eventually
you know the nearest star system from
there on this is the mentality that all
space agencies have and that's what
keeps them breathing
because they they think that we're
really going to go out there maybe even
meet the klingons you know coming our
way
never going to happen
it's never going to happen i mean
we're not going to colonize the moon
we're not going to colonize mars and
that's why you know there are
uh no more flights to the moon first of
all they're very very expensive
second the uh return on on investment is
nil
uh the best you can hope for is maybe
create a um
you know tourism
to go to the moon some people with lots
of money will say oh i'll pay for a trip
i want to go to the moon okay so they go
to the moon and go for a week or two
weeks or whatever and then come back
or maybe less i don't know
some people would be glad just to go
into space others would like to go to
the moon sure
uh no problem there
but it's just for that there's gonna be
no colony
on the moon
okay
and
you know these people don't understand
the logistics of of going to the moon in
the sense of supplying the moon
you put a base there you got to supply
it you know quite often
you know you got to give take water over
there you got to take you know
food over there
whether you're going to do grow potatoes
and you might say well they can build
one of these uh
places where you know
like
inside uh with all the lamps and so on
uh growing all kinds of food in there
it's never going to happen you know the
monster it's it is just to take all that
stuff out there for a small operation
what for
are we gonna evacuate the earth and go
to the moon which is a smaller
uh rock
okay first of all smaller much smaller
no gravity that means you have to
produce your own gravity anything can go
wrong you might lose pressure you know
loss of life the whole experiment goes
to nothing what for
who would go to the moon to live on the
moon forever
is that what these people are thinking
who would go to mars
for what
and who would pay you to go to mars so
so i pay for you to go to mars and i
never see you again
so so why did i pay for your trip to
mars
right because you're gonna stay in mars
i'm gonna stay on earth and you're not
going to have commerce with
with the earth because whatever you
bring over i'm sure i can produce a lot
cheaper here
why would i pay for your trip in the
first place
why would i contribute you know from the
earthly treasury to send you to mars
you know i mean people are
they're not thinking
they're not using their brains that's
that's what it amounts to
and then they have contradictions
because a lot of these people on the one
hand
don't believe we went to the moon
because man can't be in outer space et
cetera et cetera et cetera and then says
oh someday we're going to go to mars
well i thought you said that we can't
live in space that we can't go into
space because we will be zapped by the
sun by you know the radiation or maybe
our suits are no good we can't live out
there in space and then you're talking
about going to mars
i mean these people live with so many
contradictions just unbelievable
okay so here we have another
uh mooney
we humans never moon landing uh-huh
however we sent a lot of machinery there
okay so that wasn't near armstrong on
the moon that was a robot sorry you know
my eyesight is is failing me you know
maybe maybe i missed uh the robot i
thought it was neil armstrong jumping on
the moon okay
uh the first one record recorded is the
russian spacecraft etc in 1959 60 years
later
again we humans send robots probes
rovers so if we send all this stuff out
there if we can send
robots or whatever to the moon
why can't we send a human to the moon
i mean you gotta you gotta answer that
question because if you think that
you know we sent all this uh
uh all these
mechanical devices out there to use that
term robots etc androids maybe i don't
know uh
then why can't we send a human
i mean you're talking about you know
some trip you know uh
what is it um
slightly over a
light second to go to the moon
so if if we took that much trouble to
send all these things to the moon why
can't we send a human
and again these people live with all
these contradictions they never resolve
them okay
okay here's another
he says you literally contradict
yourself with your point regarding
mathematicians
it's the mathematicians that support
moon landing but provide no physical
evidence
evidence the guy's looking for proof
he's looking for proof for i want you to
prove to me that we went to the moon
well like i said last time i can't prove
to you that we went to the moon because
the only way i'm going to prove i mean
if i show you a movie you're going to
say that was made in hollywood okay
great so what am i supposed to do to
prove to you what evidence could i
present that we went to the moon i give
you a moon rag you say well that was
taken out of africa out of the mines or
out there in south africa or whatever
so what can i show you
what kind of evidence you want to prove
to you that we went to the moon and the
only way i can prove to him is taking
him back in time to 1969 through the
fourth dimension of course and we go
there i take him by the hand to the moon
and say look see that's neil armstrong
there and that's buzz
you know
is that the way i'm supposed to do it
so
i mean
jesus christ and uh fellow says this is
something that mankind likely will never
do we'll never go
to the moon to space to mars anything
like that it's unbelievable
and we will never
achieve flight
you know certain
speeds etc
what's the issue the issue is uh you
know he's saying that it's a
mathematician
that uh
you know vouch for this theory
this hoax that we went to the moon
and all i can tell them is that you know
the
uh mathematicians have nothing to do
with this the fact that this is
run by nasa you know i mean that's not
that's not an issue of mathematics or or
even of mathematical physics
this has to do with really with
technology whether you know we have the
technology to go to the moon whether we
have rockets that can go out into space
it's got to do with that it's got
nothing to do really with mathematics
you know or with mathematical physics so
you know again these people are
pulling at straws here to see if they
can win an argument or something i don't
know i don't know what they're into
and here's another vow it says it looks
like you have to do a lot more research
on this subject oh okay
yeah maybe i do
start small okay
start very little okay man i suggest the
pictures okay pictures now that's that's
good for evidence right
pictures okay so i'm sure they're
all hoaxes okay
look at the
hasselblad which is a camera right that
took the pictures on the surface of the
moon
okay what about it i challenge you to
find the blueprints on the modifications
for the heat cold radiation and pressure
i mean all these people come up with all
these arguments about the photograph is
wrong and the or the photograph is right
or the blueprints of the camera
jesus christ these people
they have mental problems i think they
do have actually mental problems okay
okay and here we have uh another fella
talking about vacuum also and pressure
that's one thing that gets people
you know riled up as far as the moon
landings
very top a very important subject with
them so we can't withstand the pressure
or the vacuum
and here is uh this file says people in
the flexible
uh bendable suits magical with magically
withstanding ultra high space vacuum
please
yeah they don't believe that uh
we can withstand vacuum
and that's
for me incredible that they have these
notions and they say well we can't do it
and that's it i don't believe it and
that's where it stops for them
you know
no research no thinking no nothing
and so let's go through that because
that's a big one for for a lot of these
uh people moonies you know who don't
believe we went to the moon they say you
know we can't withstand the vacuum etc
etc etc okay so here it is um
let's start here we have the uh
people who go underwater way deep
and that was one of the first suits that
went on the upper left there and what is
it you see that is very rudimentary
and this was in the 1930s
and they would drop the guy all the way
way to the bottom you know
he was under a lot of pressure in the
water remember the water has a lot more
pressure here
down there than up here in in the air
and so the guy was under a lot of
pressure but the suit was built because
they already calculated how much
pressure
uh you know the guy would need or or
anti-pressure right how much uh
resistance he would need against all
that water pressure at certain certain
uh depths in the ocean or the sea
wherever he he uh was sent
and so they already calculated they
built that into the suit and the guy
could withstand the pressure
and today we have better suits you know
and
much
uh you know they've studied
all this stuff in a lot more detail so
the technology is there
technology to go under the water is air
okay
and you may not believe it and say well
i don't believe that we can go
underwater well you know this is
something you can kill your ignorance
okay
you don't have to believe you don't have
to take my word for it okay
okay and so
that's the first step okay so
as far as i know we can go underwater
under very high pressure
can we go into the vacuum like space can
we go to 10 to the minus six torr ten to
the minus seven eight minus eleven minus
twelve
yes
we can okay
uh the answer is yes okay so here let's
let's go through this
here we have a human okay and it turns
out that you are already protected
from vacuum of space
10 to the minus 11 torr out there in the
black part right you're already
protected by air
magical air
i mean if we took all that air out you
would be exposed to the vacuum we would
all die that's how simple it is okay so
right now you are being protected from
the vacuum from the pure vacuum of space
by all this air stuff this gas that
surrounds our planet
okay
so
keep that in mind you know if you go out
there uh you have a problem because you
have no protection but right now you do
have protection here on earth and all we
have is just that uh
you know the pressure
from the air to which we are used to
right and uh and so we're protected from
all this vacuum simply by that air
natural natural protection okay
okay now here's you okay and that's you
in your suit okay
and you're out in space
and you have your spacesuit and you say
well does that really protect me
okay well um
here's you inside your suit okay that's
more or less what
you would look like okay
probably again something like that
and when you go in there you know uh
what does a suit have in there well it
has some kind of protection okay it has
some kind of protection it has already
the built-in pressure that you need to
survive no different than when you are
here on earth
in other words you have some
something in there between the skin of
your suit
and your your skin that already has the
desired pressure
no differently than the uh people who go
underwater and have um you know
protection against the pressure this is
no different
okay so so you already have
something in your suit that protects you
in that way
why would you not
accept this
you know this is this is what blows my
mind that
we already have protection
against space from the air that
surrounds us every moment
the closer you are to the earth the more
pressure there is the higher you go air
is less dense and
the more you go up there you know the
less pressure less pressure less
pressure you get after you finally get
into outer space where you get into the
minus 10 minus 11 minus 12 torr range
and of course you cannot withstand that
without a suit
okay
so the question is how do you protect
against that well just like you protect
yourself underwater by building you know
an anti-pressure suit
when you go into outer space you
build an anti-vacuum
suit
okay
and that's what they do and that's what
they test over there in the ohio
testing center that i talked about the
other day
and so
i have no idea what these people are
talking about when they say that we
cannot withstand a vacuum out there
well maybe it's the vacuum within your
between your ears that you can't
withstand that's the problem that's the
real problem
okay another fella says here he says uh
costs of
a lot of money it has no meaning
money is no object going to mars going
to jupiter you know uh
we have all the money in the world for
these things
you know uh money is no object
if we have the concept of the union of
humans for a common goal oh yeah
we have a communist on board maybe an
anarchist okay has happened for the
conquest of space in the 70s by the usa
and the ussr yeah i mean if they were
all friends right he's saying if we're
all friends the chinese the russians the
americans everybody was friendly right
instead of fighting using all that money
to fight each other what we could do is
you know pull that money and go out into
space
and maybe the counter argument is that
if we have no one to fight against uh
maybe you know maybe mother nature does
want competition
because if we have monopoly you know one
world government
uh maybe our economy goes to hell ever
think of that
anyways uh so just imagine for a moment
if all the military efforts of usa
russia china et cetera right uh
coincided with a single goal
yeah we're going to spend all that we
have well no we have no one to fight
against anymore we don't have any more
armies we don't need them because
there's no one against which to fight
we're all friendly now we all kiss and
make up we're all brothers so now we
have all this money left over that we
don't have to spend on military and all
that stuff and we can spend it on
dummy stuff like going into space for
what
for going to the moon
uh maybe to mars
to do what
i don't understand these guys these guys
think they're going to go to the moon
put a little cabin near log cabin you
know
maybe have what christmas on the moon
you know maybe in the sea you know like
the other guy
with the
hammock if we were if if it were
possible for humans to go to the moon if
it were possible
how long would it take us human to build
something there
and how uh easy would it be to keep the
facilities there yeah how how
soon would it be you know and how how
much would it take to
feed and clothe and uh
and send water up there and all the you
know besides the construction you would
constantly have to you know send all
kinds of stuff to build something on the
moon
you know maybe you need several trips
and yeah this guy apparently
has more money in bill gates he says
well i can do it you know money is no
object okay well some people have more
money and they spend it in whatever they
want i guess
and then uh
says what does mars and pluto have to do
with it okay humanity is unable to go
beyond low orbit and you announce travel
to pluto
well yeah i mean i'm i'm saying that you
know we could go to the moon to any
other moons on
of any other planets we could go to some
of the smaller planets like pluto maybe
even mercury or venus i don't know
uh we could probably get there
you know i don't know if we can come
back
we would certainly get there i think we
have the technology to get to
pluto if we want now you know don't do
it i mean
they did send pros to blue and beyond
for those of you who believe that okay
yeah and uh it doesn't mean a human has
to go you know we can send a robot and
it takes pictures whatever and we've
done that
and
what we found is that
there's a bunch of what we know already
from earth that
jupiter is a gaseous planet so is uh
saturn neptune uranus
and at the rocky planet known as uh
pluto some people say it's not a planet
and uh mercury and mars you know they're
they're just rocks
so we know that now
and
why are we gonna go there
uh you know you can't put a station
evacuate the earth colonize
conquer the martians look for
life
maybe
yeah sure
you are so limited yeah i've got
problems okay you say that the only
problem
for humanity to go to mars is to say
yes we have been there yeah exactly
that's it that's the only purpose of
going to mars now the people of nasa and
all these other space agencies
you know they have goals they say maybe
we can get to the to mars would be nice
to put a colony there you know or maybe
a station first and then
gradually build on it and build a city
and you know have all these dreams
they have all these dreams
and there's no atmosphere that we can
live on
within
mars so we would have to take our
atmosphere with us
for quite a while you know
who was it carl sagan said that it would
take
over a hundred thousand years to
terraform mars uh the the um
uh gas right to be able to live within
mars and again mars is you know would
hold a lot less
air
gas you know pressure
gravity etcetera etcetera etcetera
etcetera than uh here on earth
why would we go to mars are we are we
crowded here on earth are you feeling
elbow room
uh
problems uh maybe on the bus or whatever
and you got claustrophobia
what the hell though be more open-minded
consul let consult inform yourself study
well what can i say uh
i'm uh what does a guy say the other day
i'm old school
i just believe that man went to the moon
and back and that's it and all these
people are new school i guess
and they believe
not only that we haven't gone to the
moon or to mars right in any way shape
or form some of them believe that we
haven't gone into space some of them
believe there are no not even satellites
out there but
that someday we're going to go to the
stars and maybe even to the center of
the galaxy
what can i tell you
that's the kind of people we have out
there and and the dangerous part the
surprising for me is that i think
there's more than one percent people out
there that believe all this nonsense i
think it's maybe closer to 20 and maybe
i'm being too conservative
okay let's move on to dark matter and
what did i say
i think the mathematicians are full of
dark matter okay that's what i really
think okay okay so what do we have here
what is dark matter well dark matter is
dark
and i showed you what it looked like it
looked like uh you know black okay the
other day and it looks like that what's
underneath the green letters okay
uh but i call it the dark matter
conundrum
okay i think uh mathematicians have this
conundrum what is this problem well it
starts here okay so let's go slowly so
that you see if you can follow along
okay so uh what is it let me get this in
here
uh they put centrifugal centrifugal
force equal to gravitational force so we
have centrifugal you know towards
the uh center of the galaxy
and centripetal going out to the out
you know flying away from the galaxy and
you have all these stars going around
the galaxy
and they're pulled into the center of
the
galaxy by something called gravity
you don't know what gravity is but
somehow these stars are pulled
i hate to use the word pull because that
already shows bias but i have to use the
word pro because everybody calls gravity
a pull
i think ever since the days of newton
everybody calls it a pool and then uses
particles to prove pull
a little contradiction there anyways
uh centrifugal
uh we'll call it gravity pull and then
we have centripetal centripetal force
which is you know you swing uh the ball
around right and this thing
tends to push outwards the only thing
keeping it towards me right is the the
string
other than that uh you know the ball
if it's swung around it wants to leave
and go to another you know out of the
solar system
okay so what happens um they the problem
is they put centripetal force equal to
gravitational
that's a mathematical uh
almost a routine thing that they do
and it's deadly wrong
dead wrong for the purposes of physics
this makes no sense in physics in
mathematics
uh mathematics could be mathematics for
sure
physics never
okay so let's find out why why you can't
use
you can't put those two equal
what happens is it starts here they put
force
newton's second law right force equals
mass times acceleration equal to the
gravitational equation
this is a no-no in physics you can't get
away with doing this in physics that's
the problem okay you can't do this in
physics
okay so let's show why you can't do this
in physics give me a second here
here you have uh
newton's second law is mass times
acceleration
okay and the gravitational equation is
the gravitational constant g it's a
constant so we can almost forget about
it we're going to talk about the other
stuff there mass big mass little mass
over r squared what is r squared again
they should never use r
it's called distance
okay not r
and that's part of the problem the fact
that they use r should never be used
should be distance okay so that's the
first thing i'm going to clarify again
we'll find out why
okay
and um so what's the issue here well the
issue is that the equation on the left
mass times acceleration has to do with
distance traveled what the guy is doing
there with the little guy there right
he's pushing he's pushing the box okay
he's pushing a box
and uh and what what the mathematicians
are gonna do
they're gonna
look at his starting point and his
ending point
and they're gonna say well how many
meters how many kilometers how many
miles
they want a number
followed by units okay that's what
mathematics does and mathematical
physics
has
uses the same equation same notion they
say well we don't care about the
qualitative part the fact that he pushed
the box we want to know how many meters
how how long was the trip
okay
that's not what the gravitational
equation is about the gravitational
equation like the guys say
their little r radius which is wrong it
should be distance okay
and again you can't use radius because
uh
the earth you know compared to the moon
its radius
the the orbit of the moon
for those of you who believe that the
moon goes around the earth uh it changes
its elliptical and so on so you can't
use radius because when you use radius
you're treating it as a circle it's not
a circle you should use distance okay
because that equation gives you a single
point
for that single point you just look at
that distance
okay not radius and again radius changes
and radius the other problem with radius
is that radius is calculated in meters
and so on and that's
the other part of the problem we're not
going to be using units here we're not
going to be using numbers for anything
okay we're going to look at this
qualitatively and we're saying that that
equation on the left has to do with
pushing usually right
pushing
a box
from a to b
the other one
has to do with the distance between
a and b
and the mathematicians could never tell
in the last 400 years not a single
mathematician picked up on this that the
distance the separation between a and b
is not the same thing as traveling from
a to b why did they figure that out
because in the religion of mathematics
distance length and distance traveled
are synonyms
they don't care they don't care about
the different the qualitative difference
between length and distance or distance
traveled because all they care is about
a number
and the way they determine that number
is by unrolling the measuring tape from
a to b no matter if it's separation if
it's distance traveled or distance or
length right they don't care because
what they're going to do for distance
for length for distance travel is unroll
the tip of the measuring tape and
they're going to count how many meters
how many kilometers how many miles or
whatever
okay so this is the issue
okay so qualitatively they're not the
same not in physics they're
so so to put those two equations one
equal to another they're comparing
apples and oranges okay
okay
let me get rid of this guy
uh so here we have uh
the
equation that mass times acceleration
acceleration ends up being velocity
squared over r okay for at any start it
goes around i'm not going to derive it
you can very quickly look up on google
with
at least high school level math you can
figure that out okay but acceleration is
uh
velocity squared over r for over the
radius okay
okay so uh again we're saying those two
equations are not the same
let me get rid of this
okay so what's the issue with the stars
okay this is the issue here we have
uh the equation that they that they come
out of these two equations right one
dynamic which is the one on the left the
other one static the one that's on the
right okay and from that they derive the
equation at the bottom which is the
velocity squared is equal to the
gravitational constant g again it's a
constant we can almost omit that for the
purposes of our discussion we don't care
about that if it's going to be a
constant we're concerned about the the
big m and the little r what's the big m
well the big m is uh a big mass for
example the sun and the little m would
be the earth or the big m would be the
earth and the little m would be
the moon and the same thing happens with
a star the galaxy or the
you can say the perimeter the orbit of a
given star
anything within that orbit all the
mass that you find in there all the
stars
that's going to be the big m
meaning the galaxy so that would
represent the mass of the galaxy and the
star that's on the outside going around
the galaxy
that would be the little m okay what is
the r it's the distance between the
center of the galaxy and the star okay
and what they're saying is that velocity
of that star
going around the galaxy is related you
know the square of of the velocity we
don't care about the square because
we're interested in the qualitative
aspect here but yeah the square of the
velocity uh of that star going around
the galaxy is equal to uh ratio of big
mass in this case the galaxy
over the radius of the uh
uh
star from the distance of the star from
the center of the galaxy okay so that's
the story
okay now what's the problem with that
well uh
it creates some problems for these
people uh because here you have the
situation okay give me a second here
okay and what is it again we have
distance traveled is what you have
embodied in that little velocity okay
that's what we have that's the distance
traveled okay
and what do you have uh in the other
side well you have something different
you have distance
meaning separation okay that's that's
what we have there okay so
i want you to keep that in mind okay
and
here we have a galaxy okay and so what
are we talking about we're saying that
there you have the radius
of that star to the center of the galaxy
okay that's that little r there okay
and uh here we have another galaxy let
me get it up here
and it's got a bigger radius as you can
see there okay so one is a short radius
the other one is the long radius that's
what i'm showing there
okay
so
what happens if the radius increases
okay we're going to increase the radius
okay that radius there okay
if the radius increases then you can see
what it's going to do to the velocity
as the denominator becomes bigger and
bigger that velocity what's going to
happen to it well it's become smaller
and smaller okay so the velocity of
stars on the outside
should be slower and slower and slower
okay the farther you are the longer the
radius or the longer the distance
between the center and the outside of
the galaxy velocity should be slower
that's what i'm showing there okay
that's that's the point i'm trying to
make there
okay and um
so what's the problem with that well the
the problem is that the chart that they
built from observations of galaxies
looks more like this
that the farther you are
instead of going slower which is the
expected there from the visible disk
instead of going slower it goes faster
or if anything stays more or less the
same but never does it go slower and you
say how can that possibly be
it violates the equation okay the
equation said that the farther out you
are the longer the distance the longer
the radius okay
from the center of the galaxy to a star
the slower it should go and it should so
velocity should drop as a function of
distance okay
and that's not what we see out there
okay so this is the problem and so they
had to address this problem because they
saw it in all the galaxies
and he said hold it all the galaxies how
do we solve this problem
okay and
mathematicians you know they came to the
rescue they always saved the day okay
and so here we have our equation again
let me show it to you let's start here
again okay there we have the equation
our two galaxies okay
and so what happens when we increase the
radius okay we're going to increase that
radius okay
and there we go let's make it bigger
okay
and so now we have a bigger radius okay
so what happens well velocity should
shrink okay so how did they fix this
problem
well this is this is where the funny
part comes okay
what they did was they uh started
putting some things in there okay they
started putting some mass they said what
if we put more mass to compensate for
the longer radius okay so that way they
can keep it constant or if if you put
even more mass you can even get it to go
faster
so they so what they said is we're
missing some mass that's all that the
problem is that's the only way they
could think of that they could fix this
okay so they said let's let's put some
more mass and what they said but we
don't see any mass there okay so it must
be dark and they called it dark matter
okay so they say okay now i understand
there's mass out there you know i can't
see it so uh we'll call it dark mass and
better yet let's call it dark matter
because it's got to be some kind of
matter remember matter is mass matter
has mass or mass yeah
matter has mass okay so what they did is
essentially this they sprinkled
this dark matter in the out on the
outside of the galaxies to
produce the necessary mass okay the mass
that they needed for the equation to
come out right this is all about
equations
okay and so here you see the chart now
uh yeah if you sprinkle a lot of
kilograms out there only out there not
inside the galaxy then yeah you can
produce the result it's like you know um
this fixes the problem doesn't it you
know we we can't see the the stuff
that's out there
but if we sprinkle this
uh these kilograms out there okay then
obviously you know you can produce the
effect the necessary effect that matches
what we observe the equations now match
what we observe and we're just going to
call it dark matter
and so what they did after that was say
okay so we have our dark matter now
what we do is we look for it
so now they have the dark matter they
prove dark matter
they couldn't think of any other
reason why the stars on the outside
would go faster than the ones on the
inside so they said okay we've got it's
got to have a mass what else could it be
that's the the type of
answers a mathematician give you uh you
know a star rolls around nothing what
else could it be except a black hole
right a lot of mass in the center and
the stars rolling around
this inexistent singularity what is dark
matter same thing we don't know why the
stars on the outside go faster
very easy solution let's sprinkle some
mass there
on the outside of the galaxy i don't
know why the mass by this dark matter is
only on the outside of a galaxy but
that's where it's at why because that's
where they need it
in order for observations to match the
equations or for the equations to match
the observation so they have here the
observation they say this is what we
observe how do we fix it with our
equations very simple let's put some
mass in there and they called it dark
matter so dark matter is an equation
they've never seen it
and they
already confessed that they said we've
never seen dark matter so they don't see
dark matter it's not only it's not
really dark it's invisible
it's more than invisible it's
translucent you can see right through it
transparent translucent you can see
right through it because we can see
stars in the background
right through the edge of a galaxy
and so you say well hold it
with all these galaxies behind it we
can't see it even i mean if it's dark
and you and suddenly you know you have
the disc
of a galaxy suddenly you know with the
with another galaxy in the background or
stars in the background you know that
you should be able to see
the dark matter say oh there's the dark
matter like you know when you see
mercury or venus go across the sun
it looks like a little dark ball well
this is what you would see if you're
looking at the edge of a galaxy since
all galaxies have dark matter on the
outside right so anyone that you look at
you should be able to see the dark
matter all we have to see is some kind
of star or some kind of galaxy in the
background that kind of puts a little
contrast there we should be able to see
all those little stars
sorry all those little balls of dark
matter you know they're just painting
the outside of a galaxy you should be
able to see it and they haven't seen it
yet none of it okay
so what happens uh they gave the task to
the
accelerators to the lhc and to all these
other accelerators they're looking for
all this stuff
and here you see what
the lhc tells us the cern you know the
people who do accelerations here in
switzerland
and what they do they accelerate
particles or so they think they do and
they smash them and from accelerating
and smashing them they uh purport to
uh explain
dark they expect to find dark matter and
explain how our universe works out there
okay so we're gonna figure out what
happens out there in the galaxy by
accelerating particles here
you know in the in the accelerators and
what's the issue there well the issue
there is that remember
dark matter weighs a lot
they say a little
grain of dark matter weighs
tons
and there's lots of that out there
because you need lots of it out there to
make sure that the star travels fast
around the galaxy right
so they have to sprinkle a lot of this
stuff now they want to find those grains
of sand in the accelerators and so
here's the lac this is what they say
breaking new ground in research for dark
matter so now dark matter has entered
the accelerators the large hadron
collider lhc is reknown
for the
hunt for and discovery of the higgs
boson
but in the 10 years since the machine
call collided protons at an energy
higher than previously achieved at a
particle accelerator researchers have
been using it to try to hunt down an
equally exciting particle remember this
is a particle a hypothetical particle
that may
make up an invisible form of matter
called dark matter which is five times
more prevalent than ordinary matter and
without which there would be no universe
as we know it so if dark matter
collapses if that religion you know
falls down the drain well then they have
no
we wouldn't have a universe okay so dark
matter had better be true otherwise all
the theories about how our universe
works uh
you know uh disintegrating overnight
the lac dark matter
search searches have so far come up
empty-handed as have non-colliders
searches
but the incredible work and skill put by
the lhc researchers into finding it has
led them to narrow down many of the
regions where the particle may lie
hidden necessary milestones on the path
to a discovery okay
so uh this they continue with this it's
important to hear what these people have
to say the lac has really broken new
ground into search for dark matter in
the form of what weakly interacting
massive particles why because they say
that this dark matter weighs a lot isn't
visible but does not interact with
matter
and we're saying hold it we got a
problem what do you mean it doesn't
interact with matter if it doesn't
interact with matter how is it that uh
it affects the speed of stars
i mean if it doesn't
interact with a star why would it why
would it push
uh star to go faster
that's the issue if it's not interacting
with matter what's the point of having
this
heavy invisible particle out there that
doesn't interact with anything
yeah what does it interact with then
but
continuing here says by covering a wide
array of potential signals predicted by
either production of dark matter or
production of the particles mediating
its interactions with ordinary matter
so this stuff is not ordinary matter
it's very heavy it's invisible but it
doesn't interact with matter great i
hope they they can find it sounds like
they're talking about a ghost you know
that's what i think they're talking
about spirits the results have prompted
theorists to rethink existing ideas for
what dark matter could be yeah i mean
what is it i mean does it have shape
this dark matter does i mean does it
look like a ball
what are these people can they draw dark
matter what are we talking about bunch
of balls little balls there little beads
uh heavy no obviously
to look for dark matter the lhc has been
trying to make it by colliding beams of
protons some experiments are using
telescopes in space and on the ground to
look for indirect signals of dark matter
particles as they collide and break
themselves out in space oh yeah good
luck with that one now they're looking
for ghosts that are hitting each other
right they're going to crash against
each other maybe i hope they don't go
through each other because if they're
translucent if they're invisible
they're dark but invisible right or
again translucent if they're very heavy
but they don't interact with matter
maybe they might even go through each
other and you you'll never hear you'll
never see them collide right i mean why
would they collide others still are
chasing these elusive particles
absolutely they're chasing them right
directly by searching for the kicks or
shakes they give to atomic nuclei in
underground detectors
the main signature of the presence of a
dark matter particle in such collisions
is the so-called missing transverse
momentum to look for this signature
researchers add up the momenta of the
particles that the lhc detectors can see
more precisely the momentum right angles
to the colliding beams of protons and
identify any missing momentum needed to
reach the total momentum before the
collision
if the total momentum after the
collision is not zero the missing
momentum needed to make it zero could
have been carried away by an undetected
dark matter particle yeah it could have
been carried away by an angel also i
mean you know
i don't know what these people are
doing and you're paying for it
this is paid for
you know by tax dollars because if if
the tax dollars of the u.s for example
don't go to cern or lac it still goes to
slack and fermi lab and brookhaven and
all these other colliders and they're
doing the same thing so yeah your tax
dollars are paying for this nonsense
these people are looking for ghosts they
defined it as a ghost it doesn't
interact with matter
sounds like a ghost you know the
ghost as far as i know doesn't interact
with my curtain
some people say it does
but these people are saying it doesn't
it's very heavy
it's very invisible very translucent or
transparent
and so what are we talking about it
looks like we're talking about a ghost
this is a phantom they're looking and of
course
you know when you're looking for a
phantom it's very hard to look for it
with a telescope
or by smashing them because again if you
smash a ghost against another ghost
and they're both transparent translucent
maybe very heavy but they don't interact
with matter maybe they don't even
interact with them with each other
you know i i think you know casper would
go right through one of the other ghosts
without any problem
so i don't know uh
i don't know what these people are
looking for with your tax dollars okay
okay so here we have um this is what the
lhc does it accelerates particles okay
down the beam line and they're gonna
send them all around you know the uh the
lengthy accelerator there and they're
going to make them collide at some point
so this is where they plan to find the
uh so-called
dark matter particles here's the
collision okay
so you go in there you smash two of
these um
dark matter particles i guess or they
can smash protons i guess they're going
to produce the
heaviness of a dark matter by
smashing protons against each other
i have no idea what they're trying to do
here because if if they're going to
smash for example protons as they've
been doing to try to get a particle
that's out there in space which weighs
tons
i'm not sure you can do it with a proton
which doesn't weigh as much unless maybe
they say well it depends on the energy
with which we accelerate them okay
and yeah
if
the notion there is that energy
has to do with mass it's another form of
mass if you put enough energy
in the gazillions of uh
of whatever units kev okay or gazillions
of
electron votes yeah if you smash two of
these particles at great speeds which is
what they're talking about
maybe they can produce the weight the
the mass
of one of these dark matter particles
and when they smash them they're going
to tell you look it looks like that
because i'm sure they're going to find
it and they're going to say look there
we smashed two of these particles and
this is what we got and they're going to
say see all those those are each one of
those little guys out there that those
are the
dark matter particles rushing away from
ground zero
so this is the way they're gonna handle
it uh believe me these people are going
to find without any doubt without any
doubt they're gonna find dark matter
or their name is not albert einstein
okay so yeah
they can't fail
okay it's too big to fail
okay
how do we do it in science all this dark
matter stuff
well it's very simple and i i hate to
put it because it's just going to
embarrass these people later on when
they see it i mean
they made a monster out of this whole
thing you know a mountain out of a
molehill okay here's uh
here's uh oh by the way this is just a
comment by a guy at the lac he says
dark sector scenarios meaning dark
matter right now this uh studying that
they're doing all these evaluations
provide a new set of experimental
signatures and this is a new playground
for lhc physicists yeah you're playing
for you're paying for these people to
play there they've got all these uh
games that they're playing out there
they're
trying to accelerate protons at great
energies it doesn't accelerate the speed
but for some reason it
you know imbues
uh
a lot of mass to the protons when they
smash them i guess some particle comes
out there that is heavy enough to be
called
a dark matter particle
and they say we found it here it is
they bring it to it
here's the dark
where we found it
i know sorry it's got to be dark and got
to be more like this okay
anyways uh what is how do we handle this
in uh science again real genuine physics
okay so here it goes again i hate to
embarrass these people but here it is
okay we're saying all stars are
physically interconnected
we don't pay attention to mass we don't
pay attention to
equations we don't care about those we
just say that if all stars are
physically interconnected we have a
physical mechanism first of all for y
stars are not flung out of the galaxy
that's the first issue the second one is
that yeah
stars on the outside uh you can see why
they would go either faster or at least
at the same speed as the ones on the
inside because the whole thing rotates
like a carousel that's why okay the
whole thing
spins around as if it were made of a
single piece
okay because they're all interconnected
if all atoms in the universe are
interconnected okay so that's the first
issue
and um just in case we reinforce this by
uh showing the galactic magnetic field
okay here it is so not only does the
spire does a
galaxy spiral around
but it's um perpendicular to it we have
the uh magnetic field of the galaxy okay
and very
easily to imagine that these uh magnetic
fields they have to stretch you know
incredible amounts of distances imagine
the
magnetic field of the sun
stretches beyond pluto
and people say how can a magnetic field
go that far out and yeah and it does
it's already been measured and so on so
so the magnetic field of of our star
actually protects us from you know
interstellar
influences of all kinds you know and
it's very likely that if you put several
of these uh galaxies one with respect to
another their magnetic fields uh
probably interact
and where they do maybe we can see some
fancy things going on like you know
maybe you get black holes because you
have all this
uh all these galaxies all these uh with
strong magnetic fields and where all
these magnetic fields meet there should
be some interesting phenomena going on
in to stars that are caught in that
region okay you were talking about
magnetic fields what are they they're
threads that are swinging around the
galaxy and hitting essentially or or
sweeping by stars
and remember a star you know has
electricity and magnetism you know those
magnetic fields that you see in
uh
in the sun
what is that it means that there's some
electricity going on inside the
or certain at least in the surface of
the sun producing those magnetic fields
so we have electricity and magnetism and
here you have the magnetic field of
threads right of the entire galaxy
sweeping down on this little charged
ball
and yeah it's going to swing it around
it's got to do things to it and so
yeah
we have to look at this in physical
terms and the physical terms are threads
that's what physical is when you use
words such as mass and field and energy
you're not talking about physical
entities so you cannot explain how the
universe works the workings of the
universe gravity electricity magnetism
right you cannot explain with concepts
you
got to use physical objects you got to
identify the invisible intangible
physical objects that are out there and
in the case of dark matter very simple
dark matter simply is an inexistent
equation it's an equation for inexistent
objects things that are out there
what are out there is that all atoms are
interconnected and that means all stars
are interconnected that's the reason
stars don't fly out of a galaxy they're
not flung out of the galaxy when the
galaxy spins around
if you add to that the magnetic field of
the galaxy it maintains the integrity or
helps to maintain the integrity of your
whole galaxy
and that explains why you know all these
galaxies don't break apart and you see
them as you know when you see these up
close pictures of these galaxies what
you see is gazillions of stars just
twirling around the center that's what a
galaxy is what you don't see are the
ropes that interconnect every one of
their atoms
and you don't see the galactic magnetic
field even though even the
mathematicians accept that there is a
magnetic field they just don't pay any
attention to it
okay they never factor the magnetic
field in anything of the of a galaxy
okay let's move on to a couple questions
we had aside from the ones from the
moonies okay one fellow says
uh
i guess he says what science is supposed
to say and i think he said i'm all right
he says science says fields are just
mathematical concepts absolutely
electricity is conceptual yes
energy hasn't been defined
you get it right on the nose right
experiment uh
observations math isn't a part of the
science physics exactly weight and mass
are the same measures yeah according to
mathematical physics weight and mass are
exactly the same because they've never
been able to separate mass from weight
or weight from mass they weigh both of
them and then they tell you that mass
change
that weight change when you went to the
moon but the mass did not
well how did you determine mass well we
waited
okay so yeah mass and weight are the
same
and light doesn't slow down through a
medium exactly you got them all right
good you get a 100 points on the test
okay good
now the fella says
uh
says uh theory of stellar metamorphosis
i find really fascinating jeffrey seems
mentally ill he's talking about jeffrey
wolinski okay
pretty uh pretty sure bill is annoyed at
jeffrey for tricking him into thinking
uh the stellar metamorphosis was jeff's
idea so it's only been covered once on
bill's channel
operon i think was the first yeah
alexander apparent 1920s he wrote a
paper he wrote also a book on that and
he's the guy who really comes up with
the so-called stellar metamorphosis
theory
i think that title comes from uh
wilinsky not from um
apparent
uh i don't think o'parent gave it a name
i read the paper i don't remember him
giving it a name he just explained the
process and he says yeah look what uh
what this is is uh
is that
you know that all these planets were
made
essentially by uh
they were stars at some point they were
stars and i like the theory and i like
it for two reasons i always say that
like for two reasons one is that it
shows why
all
celestial objects or almost all of them
i mean the big ones yeah uh they're all
round they're all spherical except for
flat earth there's some flat plates
floating around but i don't i try not to
look at those
no all uh celestial objects especially
the big ones they're all round
and
uh so if the earth is round and
mars is round and
uh pluto is round and
mercury is around even the small guys
you know they're all around
ceres which is the smallest
well it's the largest asteroid but it's
also round
and then mimas one of the moons out
there which is the smallest object in
the uh
solar system
is also round and
lots of these have are
theorized to be
uh differentiated meaning that they have
all these layers inside them so they're
round and they have layers inside them
the heavier ones on the inside and the
lighter ones on the outside
what is that a description of a star
all these objects were stars they did
not form like they say the nebular
hypothesis that uh
gas is condensed
you know among other reasons because the
moons of jupiter for example why would
they be rocky while jupiter which is
next to them is gaseous
okay there's no reason for that to
happen
if if jupiter was made
through gases that were around the sun
you know condensed gases so should it
should have all these little planets
there why would they have metals you
know solid barack silicon etc carbon
and here's jupiter next to them you know
has the
structure of a star
of a small star
yeah i know uh uh the sun yeah nebular
hypothesis no problem there but uh all
the other
objects were that this the that our sun
captured
uh were already there the sun i'm saying
was the last one to ignite it was this
gas
um
cloud that condensed
a big gas cloud condensed and
captured all these objects into its
orbit that's that's
what i see here and again what the
uh this uh theory or parents theory
shows at least to me that's why i like
it it shows roundness and um
differentiation
as far as wilinsky well yeah i think uh
i don't talk to him because i think the
kids got a problem and i'm not trying to
put him down i'm just saying stating but
i think as a fact i think his loved ones
should uh
should do something for him you know i
think this kid
has some problems some issues and so
you know i think it's
not worth talking to him uh not because
i hate him or anything i don't want
people to think that i just think he's
got some real issues so yeah i think
he's
he's got to be
looked at yeah that's my take on him
okay and uh here's uh
last one says your equation belief equal
knowledge is false
[Laughter]
okay uh i didn't create the equation
okay the equation was created by mr
plato first of all and it hasn't been
improved on in the last two thousand
years two thousand four hundred i guess
more exact uh year so
uh no uh it was plato who said knowledge
is justified true belief now whether you
believe that or know that well that's a
separate issue i'm just telling you what
knowledge is out there and uh you can't
say well
that ain't what is true you gotta say
what is true
okay and this is one of the problems
that all these people have they never
tell you what is they tell you what
ain't what is ether i say well it's a
bunch of particles they say no bill
you're wrong it's not it's not ether is
not a bunch of parties
okay
and
and then the atom uh all the little
balls they don't roll around the atom
okay that's not the atom then what is
the atom
and
and the neighbor answered the question
here this guy says no knowledge is not
believed okay so what is knowledge
so they never answer the question they
just tell you what it ain't
okay you forget observation yeah we
don't we don't use our observation in
science and he says if you do not
observe how do you can how you can
factual how can you get uh factual
knowledge if you do not observe your
pencil fall down from your hands how you
knowledge the fact that the pencil fall
down to the table okay i think we
understand what he's saying uh he's
asking you know here
let's let's do it here here's the pencil
okay he says if i don't observe it okay
okay here it goes and the pencil fell
down let me do it one more time okay
just in case okay okay so if i let go it
goes down okay fine
now the question is how can you talk
about gravity how can you even begin to
explain something
if you have not used your eyes first
and uh
what can i say here's the answer you
know here's a blind man
and the poor blind man is also
quadriplegic
so he can't touch he can't sense he
can't even move his hands and he's blind
he's there you know
in his
wheelchair i guess
and someone comes to him and says
look because he's a smart man he's just
you know invalid er emblem you know he's
he's got handicaps
unfortunately yeah but he's got a good
mind and so someone comes to him
unfortunately he gets still here
and
whispers in his ear and says look
there's a pencil
and i let go of it and falls down
and i do it a million tires and it does
the same thing it always falls to the
ground never falls to the ceiling
well the blind man you know he he hasn't
seen anything he hasn't touched anything
he's just got someone who might be
telling him alive for all he knows he's
telling him in in his ear he says well
let me give you a solution what if every
atom of the pencil
is bound to every atom of the earth
that would explain why it falls to the
earth and not to this to the vacuum of
space
so he gives him an explanation without
having seen or touched or run an
experiment or done anything in fact he
can he can
put a hypothetical situation of the
klingons on the other side of the
universe so what if
what if right what if a rock hit the
moon over there on the other side of the
universe he hasn't seen it he hasn't
touched it he just what if
how would i explain it
so no to theorize you do not need to see
touch or run any experiments or make any
predictions or observe anything or none
of those
elements that the mathematical
physicists have included in their
version of science
with that i'll see you on sunday we'll
see you there bye